[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we have a brand new guess it has never
been on here before not one it's a
derogatory word for Chinese PC that
Korean people called him
what about Mexicans with that makes you
come in she comes
my mom's hella funny because like in the
store like a Mexican person would come
in and it's very shocking when a Mexican
comes into a black peeps place no she'd
be like oh next cansado my my mom that
sounds just like Mexican person person
oh I made one up for Mexicans
it's mama Jean that means being people
we already have our own are when we say
nut or bean is for Vietnamese people
Duncan how come I don't know it's very
derogatory though he's a dark on are you
babies as well
I speak video yeah my parents were born
in Vietnam even though like my blood is
like junkie dude
yeah second you have a second it's kind
of it could be used as you can see call
as a child I mean kid or [ __ ] oh yeah
child and [ __ ] are usually different
though it depends on how you say don't
you guys like like Huyen hooking means
black person but that's literally it
means dirt like dirts being right there
talking about the color of the skin so
hook means like earth so but that's not
derogatory that's actually the formal
way to say it so the derogatory term is
Camden II I'm doing is like basically
the n-word so it's very very dry so why
huggin is just like descriptives is this
the script oh that is like a earth being
dude I want to be earth being that's
Titus 5b versus like dirt color yeah
what about Indian people do you guys
planning Indian people dirty oh yeah
Indian I don't know I don't I don't know
those things could because my mom
actually just says Indian or she's just
as Mexican I think there are terms were
but I don't know yeah so Korean people
out there let us know I remember don't
I'm just kidding I wanted Sarang it's
Korea or dumb nose gum nose all the
Korean right now jaws dumb he's doing
all that there's been touching a lot of
credit not the dumb for having the worst
Korean accent ever dude it's like I was
sup guys today were to learn the word
for chip Waja yeah he has to be worse
screen sounds like a white guy so we'll
learn I'll talk about beef bulgogi okay
being you know just label the drugstore
chain um you're our favorite chunk a
dude and dude everything's be good
everything's been good lately I think
one of the most exciting things that
I've done a chance to work on lately
actually is a lot of like kpop music why
you been going to karate what I mean
Korea yeah I got a chance to go out
there work with some artists been doing
a lot of work if you work with the
kynges back home can you say who who
like the the artist nah I don't know if
we're let's say everybody but we've been
doing a lot of work with yg I've been
working with some of the groups like
winner and icon a lot lately
amazing amazing group of people really
hard-working artists out there young and
just filling the game so it's mad fun I
feel sad for k-pop artists because I
just imagine them like being whipped
with by their managers and there's like
a they're like they're like circus lions
and then the the managers are the like
watch they're like the tamers that's
what it seems like I think I'm I would
assume yes but I also assume it's kind
of like a both sides like they want the
paint's all back yeah like you sign up
for it you know what I mean like you
submit to it like for example one of the
most popular things that happens not
just in Korea right now but in general
is like it comes from like a reality TV
place it's like a it's like making a
band kind of thing right so like all
these like young boys or whatever like
that will go into these things where
they're tested rigorously on like
weekly TV shows in comical entertaining
or serious ways right there there in
dance lessons there in singing lessons
there in like a bunch of stuff in order
to like find the next Idol group and
then like from this like group of X
amount like 40 people or whatever like
that they go through these tests and
then finally there's like a finishing
like for Marvin 9 or whatever so the
interesting thing about that is this is
so many people in Korea who are into
kpop like watch those shows before they
even get there like boy band name or
kpop goober what if they're already
famous they're already like kind of
supported by the people which is why
like the culture is actually kind of
Jesus yes gene is really really amazing
which is also probably one of the
reasons why they've been able to
transcend in such an international way
in terms of like a pop music from like
an Asian country around the world so
it's pretty crazy sites now your kimchi
group is getting involved in that over
Oh for the last couple years I've gotten
a chance to work with who couple years
do step up dude [ __ ] know about his
life a little bit [ __ ] I do that well
yeah we've just been really fortunate to
get a chance to work with yeah a lot of
a lot of artists out there there was
actually this one time recently when I
was at Korea with Bing and we were we
were doing some training there that they
put us in this hotel in the middle Seoul
and we were up in like the 14th floor
just looking outside it's beautiful
compact city there's so much going on
and like just down the way there's this
Park area and there's people there like
dancing and there's a huge group they
just do this as a cultural thing out
there like people just watch stuff and
we're like dang it's people are dancing
it wouldn't be crazy if they were doing
our choreography while right and then I
was no way I was like I feel like this
is really nice I haven't heard Ford say
anything better
yes he does yeah what it means I'm
waiting for every time you open your
mouth I'm like here it goes I'll just
take it all
awesome as a dissing Hongdae uh Hongdae
I think it was we went to a park there
where people do the b-boy dancing and
stuff well they're doing kpop
choreographies so it's not like kynges
stuff but like it was quite a feat I
mean being a dummy oh yeah so the story
is they stole your moves
no because culturally out there it's
really common for people to take those
dance moves in kpop stuff and they'll
just go to the park on Saturday send it
in perform it's a bunch of kids looks
like a flash dance yeah and it's huge
crowds huge they just said then they
just watch and they're just playing they
watch and they don't cheer with any
noise oh really
great people they're better than
Japanese well we're battling you turn on
the quiet last night no we battle on
suicide rates and how quiet we can be in
concert really Koreans unless you're out
is any more but that's what I remember
when I was a kid like when I would watch
all these concerts you just see these
kids go Chinese concerts are also really
quiet outside of when they scream for
like the hardest in between but when
it's like performances and they come out
and then the performance happens is
recession shut up it's weird and I had
to ask about it cuz I was reading a
concert in China that we got to do some
work for and I was like there's nobody
like this no they're being respectful
yeah and they're like no it's just how
it is and I was like I had to think
about how's it why then I was like oh
they don't serve alcohol concerts
what's up tightest [ __ ] everyone's sober
and chill and cold and just waiting for
the back yeah and it's like that oh yeah
you know I like in America there's a lot
of like make some noise they'll get like
crowd work like left side right side
they don't do anything I never witnessed
it oh do have you been on a Japanese
roller coaster it's the most silent
thing ever it was a little bit it was
wild we saw that Disneyland we went to a
roller coaster and all judge people like
yes us three screaming and then everyone
else ever I still used to that though
but they still put their hands up though
you hear like you're like yeah I like
that a bit when they
how quiet it is yeah so that's been
that's been really really fun it's all
like in the shadows all right because
like on those words y'all come on we
know your branding so we caught it thank
you appreciate it
can't someone catch me up to speed it's
not Korean ninjas all right it's Kim as
in kinfolk my friends is not it's not in
the limelight is is a big part of like
my personal area of career right now
it's a really interesting kind of like
place where I'm doing a lot of dance
work and like nobody knows about it you
know if you like that you better pray
that like you should answer
you chose that like hobby it's great I
think it's just an interesting line like
TV show I think a balance of both is
necessary to be like a successful
professional you know you know who you
shot a followed you should have followed
the career path of JLo acting I'm
cooling that's a dancer that's a dancer
that became success yeah for sure
so the next move for you is to get a
really nice ass I start performing in
c-list movies and then they run in like
up daddy get on in living color be a
dancer you know how it is well get on
SNL be a backup dancer for us oh no the
only one I don't you know I'm to be
honest I don't know if I'm actually
built like that to be like like mega
star sex God yeah I'll say with mega
star I feel like you probably more to
yourself a little bit and you're not as
being I don't think I'm felt to be a
megastar you there and when I say paying
too I'm saying that there has to be a
some like some sort of vanity to one you
have to you yeah yeah it's something bad
but people who do like the limelight
it's vanity and you have to have that if
you don't you're gonna struggle with the
line when it's narcissism yeah you have
to have it though but if you don't you
have to you have to want if you have to
you after that you also have to believe
that you're in that person it's like
Kanye sometimes you're like Kanye it's
crazy but if it wasn't crazy he wouldn't
go that far
yeah I'm Kanye and I do dope [ __ ] that
was the first thing he said to what Dave
Chappelle when he was a nobody
yeah I don't think I even came out at
the time he's like I'm Kanye I do dog
[ __ ] yeah he was like the most
egotistical one out of the group of
actual celebrities you already believe
in himself yeah but he has the skills to
back it up so he was very like prophetic
in that says well we're specifically
talking about for limelight though when
it comes to like artistry though like I
enjoy the moments while I like have to
be crazy
it's like Fink crazy I don't even think
I'm like that what do you mean think
crazy sometimes like you get in the
humdrum of doing like professional work
so much that you do it a certain way
right and you whether you're doing
people whether you're doing it for the
job whether you're doing it for what you
think is yourself but really what you're
doing for yourself you just trying to
make sure you continue to get jobs you
know yeah so like there's every now and
then I feel like sometimes in my head or
my heart you feel like you want to snap
and you want to just do something even
if even a people like don't receive it
the way that is how I live my life
that's why I'm not successful see you're
[ __ ] up if they don't don't be a
David so dude don't take your channel
just delete the hope you start a bucket
I took my channel I gave it over to our
competition oh that's that's what I mean
like your competition yeah we turned it
into the arena dance competition YouTube
channel I was talking about one day
context I hit a barn in Geo because I
you know big role models of mine thank
you thank you very nice we talked about
the patent podcast that never came out
but we're we're talking about we're
talking about you know migrating your
channel over to like a different brand
and stuff like that and at that time was
that very pivotal moment where I was
already stopping the whole like let me
push Anthony Lee is it individual brands
like what specific like ideals and the
brand of like kyndra's together because
it's just a bigger voice and you could
do more and impact more people versus
like individual legacy you guys know
that story so turning my channel its
arena was like after watching what you
guys have done with barbell Brigade and
it was just like you know made a lot of
sense very inspiring but that's just a
testament to the idea of like the
limelight for the individualism is not
something that I wanted to seek as much
as I've already been
wit yeah whatever minimal that amount is
and I enjoy it but at the same time like
going far there's daunting so I'm enjoy
the fact that I'm in a part of my career
where I'm doing a lot of in the shadows
work you know it's like good work and
nobody really knows about it but
sometimes I have to be like I'm still
alive hire me I still do cool stuff
sometime have to be more vein
I'm telling you didn't you can't post
this [ __ ] like you can never like put it
out to the public John Thomson you know
it's like a double-edged sword I feel
like sometimes with artists especially
too like they might not want you to or
the label they might not want you to put
out the artistry that like you had
created for them cuz um sometimes they
do you like Paris I don't know how to
say your last name cabal Hilton how is
it Cobell yeah like her like she does
choreo for Rihanna she does choreo for
Sierra
but like she'll put it like she and
she's like a celebrity herself so to
speak right so maybe that's like a
relationship that they'll have what the
record was like yeah yeah you post this
- it'll be great well you're bigger than
her no no no no no no no no no no I'm
not I don't know about industry but just
in terms of numbers okay I'm pretty sure
she's way more popular than me yeah you
know another dancer that became really
famous recently
fighting Neverland oh oh no no straight
up I'm gonna be a [ __ ] about it right
now I refuse to watch that ya know cuz
every one of my close homies literally
said it ruined all the music and the
problem is it's not that I don't want to
seek the truth it's at the music place
everywhere and I don't want to be ruined
is that sensitive dude listen Anthony it
is the most hilarious documentary you'll
ever see dude it's [ __ ] comedy it's
not true don't worry about it
[Music]
yeah don't worry about let us go right
now me meeting Joe at high school never
doing drugs and him going come on man
just take a hit don't worry about it
don't worry about convincing me to take
a hit I know and you're gonna have a
dope-ass time with me just know just
know this that within the documentary
it's not like the r.kelly situation
where you see this video proof this is
just people's accounts of stories with a
lot of shady stuff behind it so when i
watch the docu-series i was cracking up
oh it's very serious but when somebody
says that Michael Jackson told me to go
to a corner spread his butt cheeks and
jack off to his butthole that is
hilarious
I didn't finish just watch the first
part in like half of it it's hard it's
hard it's just like a it's like do you
want to see a two-hour life vest it's
hilarious to our life all right let me
tell you why okay there's already
there's already a lot of evidence that
kind of doesn't work with what they've
said one really really big one is James
safe Chuck right there's two guys that
that accused Michael of molestation
right and and if you don't know anything
about their history then it's you feel
very sorry for these guys but if you
knew a lot of the backstory and what
went down and the motives and the
reasons then you go oh it makes [ __ ]
sense like if you're a big Michael fan
and you know and you've been following
this stuff you understand it which I am
right so here's one of the biggest lies
biggest [ __ ] lie okay Jane's safe
shot in the documentary said he was
molested repeatedly all over never
Neverland Ranch right he has a very
graphic story about being molested
inside of the train station upstairs and
all that stuff at the time of his
allegation he was around like 11 years
old or 12 years old right but evidence
comes out that the change station was
built when he was 17 years old didn't
exist it didn't exist during the time he
was visiting the Neverland Ranch and and
so people are coming out and say well
you know memories faulty and whatever
but dudes I'm I'm 35 and I know
distinctively the difference between a
lean seven
teen and 11 you could be 60 years old
and there's a huge gap between now if it
was like if you're 11 and maybe 13 maybe
yeah especially if I don't know but I
remember traumatic experiences you don't
forget that [ __ ]
because being 17 and 11 is a huge
[ __ ] gap that's a huge gap so what
ended up happening was Oprah took down
the interviews that she had with them
and and they're not gonna Riera HBO's
not gonna re air the Finding Neverland
documentary all that stuff because there
it's still up I just saw it well it's
still going through its run it's not
gonna go run something yeah everyone
yeah but they're basically men a lot of
people knew that they were this is a
money grab sucks
ah like I said I'm down to be a [ __ ] on
this particular topic because like death
or death will really impacted my life
with his music you know what I mean and
a lot of that stuff so I'm like all I
see is disdain and sadness unlike a lot
of like you know peers faces from
hearing things I even true or not it's
it's a dark and you think about that
music you thinking about the sound of
the music you're thinking about the
titles and things like pretty young
thing which isn't that isn't that full a
part of the dance world though yeah Wade
Robson is huge right huge in the dance
yeah for was a meaty cheesy boy from the
jack-in-the-box commercials to does it
make me a bad person
that I still listen or Kelly yes yeah
because you know they he's a shitty
person but I wish I wish don't do that
sure him seeking and saying please
forgive me I [ __ ] his dog his his [ __ ]
is so like like true to the [ __ ] he was
doing oh it's in the yeah but I separate
the art from I think so and also so art
to me also is a communicative medium for
example as much as Leonardo da Vinci
wants to put into Mona Lisa the other
half of the art is how it makes me
emot-- so with our Kelly stuff like
although he was despicable and he made
whatever art he made when I would say he
was a chef right and he was a [ __ ]
like
kid molesting chef he was able to like
throw portobello mushrooms into the
pasta when I'm eating the when I'm
eating the food half of the experience
is still on my side I'm like yeah this
is [ __ ] bomb I don't go oh man these
carrots this carries it's about the
support that you're giving the artist
because I'm between both of you actually
like a I kind of still want to hear the
music but then I can't because of that
cuz they're back so I don't listen to
our Kelly anymore just because of my
support for her but if I was walking in
the mall by myself I would snap my
fingers
yeah just playing some people so it's
it's like when you're not eavesdropping
because it's just in this space and
you're just kind of okay well I'm not
gonna change I keep I can't deny it's a
good song David I can't deny that he was
gonna be at my wedding good I feel like
this is the thing right some people feel
that it's tainted and other people don't
that's just a difference so if the
artist is some kind of weirdo and then
it comes out that they're they dare
pedophile whatever then it taints the
memory that they have well other people
be like well no I still had those
memories and it was I at that time I
didn't know he was a molester or
whatever I know because I don't supply
him because I pirated those songs so
technically I didn't pay for it so
technically I'm in the green yeah in my
book I would be like yeah see Bill Cosby
- this is not supporting the artist then
like I big human behavior Lee [ __ ]
supported Cosby right
bad move now i so i but i still watch
The Cosby Show that's still my favorite
sitcom till this [ __ ] day because a
lot of the stuff in The Cosby Show
molded Who I am today but doesn't mean
that I'm gonna stop watching the cop
that's why I think art is two-sided
there's the side that the artist created
but there's also the consumer experience
that I don't think you can really deny
either so for me I'm like the art that
they make and put out into the public
it's as much that artists as well as
mine you know I think this Michael
Jackson become part of my child
experience is different from what who
they are yeah if I had known that prior
to watching it then I definitely
wouldn't have and it's not like Michael
Janis is alive and
or our Kelly's gonna like make new music
that I'm suddenly gonna go to this cause
yeah yeah yeah you know what I mean it's
like old Kelly Bates um [ __ ] right now I
want to watch it just to watch them
suffer like the
I admit song we've got so many hit ok
show was so funny